as the kids head back to school it's
time to get that summer dust dirt and
traffic out and get back to clean and no
one does that better than our friends
from zerorez the sponsors of this
segment and joining me to tell us more
is one of the owners ben mckee welcome
back and brother doug you guys this is a
family business and i love how you guys
run it because you truly take care of
your customers they mean everything to
you absolutely and we love las vegas
we've been in vegas for nearly i don't
know i've been here for the last 10
years i went to elementary school here
it's like art's our home we love it now
zerorez has been cleaning my home for
probably that long if not longer and
there's something about zero res clean
you don't use soaps you don't use
detergents how do you get your carpet so
clean you know our magic is our
technology we clean with what we call zr
water and this technology eliminates it
eliminates the soaps it eliminates all
the harsh residues that other
traditional methods leave behind and you
get a better clean a safer clean and a
cleanup last longer than anything else
it really does last a long time and what
i also love about xero resin tell us a
little bit more about this you don't
just clean carpets you clean a lot of
different things we do if you're looking
to revitalize your tile and grout
upholstery
stone air ducts we clean it all
our approach is we have a service for
every surface that you have and that
includes
mattresses if you've never had your
mattress cleaned try it you'd be
surprised at what comes out in there
that's great there's a lot of pollen and
allergies in those things let's talk
about pets you specialize in pet stains
too we do we've got an arsenal of
products that safely and effectively
address not only the odor but also the
stains that are left behind by our fur
babies and that that two-step approach
it makes it like it didn't even happen
almost i love seeing zero resin action
we're gonna um take a look here you
always bring in the most disgusting
carpet i don't know where you get this
from is this from us your clients oh
yeah we ripped it out
it's disgusting but i love doug you do
your magic swipe and it's just amazing
i and i always say it's the one swipe
that you can see the difference and then
imagine when they go over it a few times
yeah wow look at that that's crazy and
this is our vacuum's hooked up to the
truck's engine so it's like having a 300
horsepower vacuum and you can see right
away with one pass one it almost looks
like it came new from the factory and
you don't do just one pass in the home
you actually do several passes we do we
clean it until it looks good and it's
clean
i am truly in awe now let's say you have
a business and people are coming back
into the workplace maybe they haven't
been there because of the pandemic you
guys do workplaces too we do we clean
offices casinos hotels we have a
dedicated commercial department
and we run nearly 24 7. so we can
accommodate your schedule uh work around
your your staff and make your place
healthy and hygienic you guys have been
voted best of las vegas for a very long
time how many years have you guys i
believe it's four four four years in a
row it's definitely well deserved and
when you guys come on the show you
always have a special offer for our
viewers tell us what you're offering we
do right now you can get your carpets
cleaned
it's a great time of year to get them
cleaned
you can get two rooms for only 89
and we're throwing in an additional 20
off pet treatment so take advantage of
it that's always fantastic thank you
guys so much for coming on the the work
speaks for itself they are the best
people and you can feel safe having them
in your home thank you again to zerorez
for sponsoring this segment take
advantage of their back to school back
to clean special like like you said two
rooms of carpet cleaned for only eighty
nine dollars plus save twenty percent on
pet treatments just call seven oh two
eight four zero thirty three thirty
three or go online to zerorez las vegas
dot com for more minimums apply